you're living at home with your family
your parents you're renting with a buddy
and you're considering buying or even if
you're a homeowner considering selling
pay attention to this
clip right here basically meet kevin
is basically saying
now is the time to sell sell sell sell
sell don't even think twice this is the
time to sell then you got graham stefan
basically saying the bubble is getting
ready to pop now people are listening to
these people i see you shaking your head
so i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this these are people who are quote
unquote real estate experts saying this
is the time to get the hell out of your
house and sell aka it's the top of the
market now if you don't believe these
guys because they're young and maybe
you're not necessarily
find them to be credible let's read
something else jamie dimon this guy
who's a billionaire
he runs
jpmorgan chase a bank you might have
heard of
um
he's the ceo of that his quote unquote
says he feels a storm is coming to the
real estate
marketplace so my question is this
tiffany are we at the top of the market
right now okay i really like this
question because there is a lot of
different information out there and you
kind of have to take pieces and bits and
pieces and formulate your own opinion
right i do listen to economists and my
most recent economist who's very well
respected was sharing that you know
we're not in a bubble yes is there gonna
there's you know are the rates are
increasing what does that mean that
means affordability is decreasing right
that means that now that let's just say
there's a hundred buyers out there that
can buy this million dollar home well
maybe there's going to be 50 right so
when affordability it goes down then of
course there's going to be less buyers
in the market what else is going to go
down the competition right so what's
going to go up inventory so you have to
look at all these things and consider
okay so that's gonna definitely cause
some buyers to maybe step out of the
market or lose the you know range of
affordability that they wanted to be in
so that's gonna cause an adjustment
right now when we talk about people like
crash it's gonna crash you know i'm like
okay let's put some things into
perspective especially for us floridians
okay we have a kick ass state can i even
say that yeah of course okay
guys we do have a kick ass okay um
so many reasons that people move here
lucky us we're in real estate we're
definitely riding this wave but think
about it what people pay for like shoe
boxes in places like certain parts of
california new york new york city
millions of dollars for these things
people have found us out here in florida
yeah they know what you can get in the
sunshine state with great tax benefits
right so you think about it and like i'm
selling 5 000 square foot homes that are
under a million dollars in the central
florida park market and you can't get
that in certain other markets so
why i say this is because look at it in
perspective of the growth that florida
still has the future we still have
what's being invested into our state
infrastructure i mean people are
investing here they're moving here for
many reasons so i feel like we still
have a really great um trajectory for
growth in our markets especially like
you're in the luxury market you see what
people are buying they can't believe
what they can get for 23 million dollars
on star island i mean maybe it's more
now right but i'm just giving you an
example like compared to what they pay
for a shoebox in manhattan so i think
that for florida and again it's all i
think market driven we still have so
much potential for the growth of the
values in our markets now of course
rates are going to definitely adjust
like make an impact on that and what it
means for the market but from what i
read and the the economist i follow
crash no adjustment correction yes but
no crash and for the future of the state
of florida i say yeah sure cash out if
you have the opportunity because you
have a great you know
you've increased your value so much and
you have great equity but also continue
to buy here we still have so much growth
ahead so i'm big on florida real estate
buy sell
all of it are you seeing more people
looking to buy right now or look more
people looking to sell what's your
market i still see um a lot of people
coming in and wanting to move down here
and looking and it's just it's still
hard to find property so you still have
the you know the supply demand issue you
know there's still a lack of inventory i
am seeing a little bit more inventory
coming coming to market um but the
prices you know people are also pricing
their property so crazy high that they
that those kind of sit there and they're
not necessarily real sellers as you know
we say because they're just trying to
get a certain number that's a little
unrealistic so those properties sit for
a while but the properties that do go on
the market that are well priced or gone
are gone right away i mean usually even
like the first second day they get
listed um but i'm still seeing a ton of
buyers coming in town and we can't you
know we can't find them places and also
those those people that do want to sell
they say where would we go so if they
sell their let's say 10 million to 5
million 10 million home
they're you know even if they made a
couple million bucks on it in the last
year and a half like where are they
going to go they're going to have to uh
pay a bigger a bigger price tag with no
inventory yeah that's bingo that's i
hear that all the time it's like i might
get a great price for my property but
then what the hell
then you're back into the marketplace
i'm trying to buy a property that's too
expensive and is over inflated and you
kind of it's cyclical well i'll tell you
too so it depends i think now more than
ever you have to be creative okay and
you have to be educated and experienced
to do well in this market right so for
instance a client wants to sell they're
like but where will i go tiffany okay
well there's a few options for you
number one we can put the house on the
market we can require a lease back for a
certain amount of term to say hey at
least we're going to know that somebody
wants it how much we might be able to
get and we're going to get a lease back
to give you the time to find something
else right option a option b a bridge
loan people don't know about bridge
loans right so you can essentially
secure your next home first and then go
and sell your first home maybe you
didn't have the cash to do both at once
there are different programs out there
called bridge loans so if you're working
with somebody experienced they're going
to be able to guide you on this you know
and i do a lot of our off-market stuff i
get creative as hell i spend a lot of
money on private mailers to homes and
different things because i find
off-market deals for my clients it's the
only way i'm going to be able to compete
and not have to have multiple offers
bidding them outside well over what
it'll appraise for right so i get
creative as well so there are ways to
still win in this market and not be
paying the knucklehead price but you
have to be with a professional that can
guide you to do that all right let's
stop right there with this professional
thing yeah that was bars i feel like
that's awesome i don't know exactly what
she said but i know that if i was in the
real estate i'd rewind
[Music]